health workers in Cameroon raised to
contain the spread of copied 19
infections door-to-door testing is
underway in several regions of the
country and for good reason the virus
has been spreading here and authorities
fear the number of infections could be
higher than reported on the first day of
this operation at least 100 new cases
why discovered though there is one group
of health workers in the field to
identify suspected cases while at the
same time another group is cleaning and
communicating suspected areas every
community leader is involved in the
process the number of surgeon
infractions seen in the first week of
testing is raising concerns among the
population there are more it's the fear
of death that's got to everyone if you
get the virus you'll be put in
quarantine for 14 days with no chance of
leaving home but there are bills to pay
one must earn to do that Duda Stan's
social distancing is the hardest of all
we also fear African governments may not
contain this pandemic this will result
in total chaos in Africa at the end of
it all we may not be able to do anything
but cry and lament like many African
countries Cameron's healthcare system
isn't prepared for the pandemic experts
say if infections get out of control
here it could be catastrophic the
authorities in the city of Dwolla are
moving head to convert the city stadium
into an isolation and treatment center
they anticipate arise in infections and
not everyone in the city is willing to
be tested for the virus a source of
concern for health officials along with
plans for mass testing a decontamination
of public spaces is also underway but
that's not enough to come some
Cameroonians cities are if Western
countries with all their facilities and
equipment accounting huge losses what do
you say of Africa when infections reach
a peak it is really scary for everyone
I'm waiting to see but to be frank
things don't seem right the more you
think about it the more you want to give
up African Union and other regional body
say they are working with individual
governments to provide equipment and
supplies to deal with the pandemic but
four institutions are states struggling
to fund their operations it's hard to
say if that support will come soon
enough to avert a major health crisis on
the continent Hamid Idris al Jazeera